[Music]
the upcoming game of thrones prequel
series house of the dragon is based on
the georgia or martin's targaryen
history book fire and blood
hbo is developing a new game of thrones
prequel show based on george r
martin's tales of dunk and egg which
followed the adventures of sir duncan
the tall dunk
and young aegon v targaryen egg 90 years
prior to the events of a song of ice and
fire
to some of you this might come as a huge
unexpected surprise
but i've been waiting for this
confirmation for quite some time
on february 10 2013 george r martin
confirmed that he had been in discussion
with hbo over a possible adaptation of
the tales of dunk and egg short stories
and ever since i knew it would sooner or
later be official
the game of thrones ended in 2019 the
game of thrones prequel series house of
the dragon will air in 2022
and now variety reports that hbo is in
early stages of developing another
as yet unnamed spin-off show based on
george or martin's tales of duncan egg
the tales of dunk and egg is an ongoing
series of prequel novellas written by
george rr martin
set in the world of a song of fights and
fire the stories relate to the
adventurers of the hedge knights are
duncan at all
who would become a legendary member of
the kingsguard and his squire
egg who would become king aegon the
fifth targaryen of westeros
although egg is a boy at the start of
the series he will eventually grow up to
become king aegon v
or aegon the unlikely the stories begin
with their meeting 90 years before the
events of game of thrones
and may cover the events until the
deaths of duncan and king aegon
martin has published three novellas in
the tales of duncan next series to date
the hedge knight in 1998 the thorne
sword
in 2003 and the mystery knight in 2010.
the three novellas were then collected
and published together as
a knight of the seven kingdoms in 2015.
the tales of duncan egg begin 90 years
before the war of the five kings
at the end of the reign of king daron ii
targaryen
the realm is still recovering from the
first blackfyre rebellion 13 years
before
a great civil war that tore the seven
kingdoms in half
there on the second bastard half-brother
daemon blackfyre had tried to seize the
throne in the rebellion
but was killed in the final battle of
the war several of his sons survived by
fleeing into exile
and across the narrow sea house
blackfyre is continually plotting all
manner of intrigues
against the main branch of the targaryen
dynasty
hoping to gain support for new
rebellions the targaryens are still
having difficulty maintaining their hold
on power
particularly since the last of their
dragons died 50 years ago
and the beasts are starting to fade from
living memory
there are also lingering tensions from
the recent unification of dorne
with the rest of the seven kingdoms the
fiercely independent dornishmen had
resisted targaryen conquest for two
centuries
and only finally came under the
authority of the iron throne through a
peaceful marriage alliance
thereon ii mary did the sister of the
prince of dorne and aaron the second
sister married the prince of dorne
the terms of the alliance led to the
iron throne giving house martel of dorne
preferential treatment
but a strong primordial faction
developing around darren ii
at the royal court this is one of the
factors that sparked the blackfyre
rebellion
as all of the non-dornish lords who felt
that
the promartel faction was receiving
royal favors
which should have been theirs ultimately
sided with daemon blackfyre
despite 13 years of relative peace
relations between the dornish and the
rest of the seven kingdoms remain
tenuous
worse problems are on the horizon as
during the course of duncan eggs first
adventures
a massive plague known as the great
spring sickness
sweeps across the seven kingdoms
westeros equivalent of the black death
upsetting what was already a fragile
political balance
with plague and drought devastating the
seven kingdoms many turned to banditry
to survive
and the roads are crawling without low
bands petty feuds erupt between local
lords competing over food and resources
with the realm weakened from within
dangers arise on every side
as the targaryens enemies see their
vulnerable state as a perfect
opportunity to attack
besides the continuing tensions with the
dornish to the south
the black fires across the eastern sea
are tempting to raise new armies in the
free cities
and to turn lords investors to their
side who are upset that the difficulties
the targaryen reign is encountering
to the best the ironborn led by dagon
greyjoy are seizing their best chance in
generations to return to the old way
conducting brazen coastal raids from
bear island in the north to the arbor in
the south
to the north the wildlings have been
united by a new king beyond the wall
raymond redbeard and they are preparing
to cross over the wall
and sweep through the lands to the south
into this backdrop steps are dunking the
tall
a very large squire who grew up as an
orphan in the slums of flea bottom in
king's landing
a hedge knight sir ireland of penetrate
has died during the night
his squire a large young man named dunk
buries him and pays his last respects
after considering several options doug
decides to continue his journey to
ashford
and compete in the tourney as a knight
he adopts her
orleans armor as his own as well as his
equipment three horses
and remaining monies at then inn on the
road he meets a boy with a shaved head
named egg
who secretly follows him to ashford
impressed by the boy's spirit
dunk takes simone as his own squire for
the upcoming tourney
at ashford dunks sells one of his horses
to commission armor
then attempts to enter the lists of the
tourney without proof of his knighthood
he's nearly barred from competition
until prince bailor targaryen vouches
for him
dunk watches the first day of
competition amongst the commoners
we tag on his shoulders after several
spectacular tilts
the day ends when prince aryan targaryen
disgraces himself by killing sir
humphrey harding swords
that night egg informs dung that a
puppeteer girl he had met earlier is
being beaten by prince aryan
dun clips to her defense and attacks
aryan striking him in the face
as a royal guard the rests dunk egg
reveals himself to be aryan's brother
prince aegon targaryen
commonly known by his nickname egg a
grandson of king there on the second
in jail dunk chooses to take a trial by
combat rather than losing his hand
princerion demands the combat to be a
trial of seven
as his brother prince daeron also
accused dunk of kidnapping aegon from
his charge
dunk must find six champions to fight
with him against seven accusing knights
or he will forfeit staff and fossilway
is the first ally dunk finds
and he and egg bring more champions to
dunk scones
the 14 champions line their mounts along
opposite sides of the turning grounds
and charge
dunk tilts against aryan but is quickly
unhorsed
although nearly defeated dunk manages to
grapplerion and use his size advantage
to pummularion into submission
arion recants his accusation ending the
trial
the fighting costs the lives of both
countries
prince baylor who had not brought his
own armor but instead wore
armor and made for his son took a blow
to the head from a mace
after the battle baylor approaches dunk
to congratulate him
and begins to act drunkenly when his
crushed helm is removed
it's shown that the weaker armor made
for his son did not protect him from the
blow which has crushed in his skull
aryan's father may carr meets with dunk
after the funeral
revealing that it was his mace that
killed baylor
he regrets aryan's behavior and offers
dank a position in his household to
train aegon
dunk insists on being allowed to travel
and offers to take aegon as a squire to
learn to be a better knight than aryan
makar agrees making sure aegon continues
to use his alias of egg
to avoid scandal duncan eggs set out to
dorne
in search of the puppeteer whom dunk had
saved
through a series of many adventures the
unlikely duo of dunk and egg will in the
course of years rise to great fame
as egg grows to become king aegon the
fifth and dank becomes sir duncan the
tall
lord commander of the kingsguard martin
has said that the novellas will include
time jumps
so they will ultimately cover the rest
of the lives of the two main characters
stretching across a period of 50 years
until both of them die in the tragedy of
summerhall
this will bridge the timeline between
the two main narrative eras
sir barcelony was knighted at the age of
16 by king aegon v
after end horsing sir duncan in a joust
timing lannister's grandfather gerald
lannister is a character in the early
novellas
but young tywin was a boy when aegon v
died
prince rhaegar targaryen was also born
the very same night as the tragedy at
summerhall
no writer or talent is currently
attached to the project
but sources say it's a high priority for
hbo
as the premium cabler looks to build on
the success of game of thrones
should the project go to sirius it would
be the second game of thrones prequel to
make it to screen
the network is currently prepping the
series house of the dragon
which slated to debut in 2022 that show
will document the build-up to the
targaryen civil war in westeros
that's known as the dance of the dragons
fans have been calling for a tales of
dunkin egg tv series
for some time now and now we might
finally get it
it's important to note that hbo has just
started developing the show
but it's good to know that we'll get
more of esro's and its stories
in the meantime we have another game of
thrones prequel house of the dragon
to keep us in touch with the magic world
of westeros which will be about
targaryen history and which is going to
air in 2022
thank you guys so much for watching and
let me know which game of thrones
prequel excites you more
tales of duncan egg or house of the
dragon if you enjoyed this video please
give it a big thumbs up and i hope to
see in the next one peace